everyone sees what you appear to be
few experience
what you really are
[Music]
if an injury has to be done to a man
it should be so severe
that his vengeance need not be feared
the first method for estimating the
intelligence of a ruler
is to look at the men he has around him
there is no other way to guard yourself
against flattery
then by making men understand that
telling you the truth
will not offend you
never was anything great achieved
without danger
[Music]
never attempt to win by force what can
be won by deception
men are driven by two principal impulses
either by love
or by fear
it is not titles that honor men
but men that honor titles
where the willingness is great
the difficulties cannot be
great since love and fear can hardly
exist together
if we must choose between them
it is far safer to be feared than loved
[Music]
whosoever desires constant success
must change his conduct
with the times
of mankind we may say in general they
are fickle hypocritical
and greedy for gain
therefore
it is necessary to be a fox to discover
the snares and a lion
to terrify the wolves
[Music]
there is no avoiding war
it can only be postponed to the
advantage of your enemy
in conclusion
the arms of others either fall from your
back
or they weigh you down
or they bind you fast
it is better to act and repent
than not to act at regret
he who builds on the people
builds on the mud
[Music]
nature creates few men brave
industry and training makes many
one should never fall in the belief that
you can find someone to pick you up
he who is highly esteemed
is not easily conspired against
[Music]
men sooner forget the death of their
father than the loss of their patrimony
the best fortress which a prince can
possess
is the affection of his people
men intrinsically do not trust new
things that they have not experienced
themselves
it is double pleasure to deceive the
deceiver
men should be either treated generously
or destroyed
because they take revenge for slight
injuries
for heavy ones they cannot
any injury we do to a man must be such
that we need not fear his vengeance
it is a common fault of men
not to reckon on storms in fair weather
it is far better to earn the confidence
of the people
than to rely on fortresses
everyone around
will envy you if you tell the truth
he who wishes to be obeyed
must know how to command
a man cannot survive without cheating
because it
is his nature
men will not look at things as they
really are
but as they wish them to be
and are ruined
[Music]
you